first up how to keep your knife sharp
it's far harder working in the kitchen
with a blunt knife than it is with a
sharp knife the secret behind keeping a
sharp knife sharpen it before and every
time you use it
first grip the steel feel really
comfortable about holding the still
imagine you're holding a tennis racket
or you're playing squash you've got to
be really comfortable with it now 45
degrees confident grip confident grip
with the knife this is the butt of the
steel really important to keep your
fingers behind there you never grip a
steel with your fingers over that
because the knife comes back in you've
just lost a finger always grip behind
nice long strokes so we get the whole of
the blade
over steel
stroke
and we start from the bottom to the top
so there
across
there
across
slow strokes over the top of the steel
and then come back underneath
then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now
that's ready to start chopping
to stop your chopping board rocking or
slipping a great tip is to simply wet a
kitchen cloth kitchen paper or tea towel
and place it underneath
[Music]
now you can chop with confidence
[Music]
my next top tip is get the most out of
your humble veg peeler
it's brilliant for slicing ultra thin
ribbons or veg perfect for asian dishes
great for making long delicate parmesan
shavings to top soups and salads
it also makes wonderful chocolate curls
your pepper mill is more versatile than
you might think tighten the top screw to
get finely ground pepper ideal for soups
and sauces
[Music]
for general seasoning you want it medium
ground so set the screw in the middle
and loosen it right off for coarse
pepper perfect for steaks and fish
[Music]
peeling garlic for one clove simply bash
it with the back of a knife and the skin
comes off easily
for a whole head crush separate into a
bowl
cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds
then simply pick out the peeled cloves
how to chop an onion this is the root
that's absolutely crucial leave that on
there if you cut that off the onion will
start to bleed and you'll start crying
rapidly
slice going forward let the weight of
the knife do the work
three fingers
one in front two behind and this part of
the knuckle is going to guide the knife
fingers on top of the onion point the
knife towards the root and try to get
as close to the root as possible nice
long
stroke
and then push the onion back together
push the knife halfway in to the onion
slightly tilt the knife down
one at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in place
with the weight of the blade to cut
through that onion to get to the base of
the root
again turn it round
up and down motion
and that's what we're left there no
waste just the root
and look
there
you've got a really nice finely chopped
onion
so much great cooking depends on
starting with a high enough heat if a
recipe calls for a hot pan put it on
early so it gets smoking hot and always
remember to preheat your oven at least
20 minutes before cooking
a clean cook is an efficient cook my tip
for a tidy cooking area is to always
have a waste bowl next to you it saves
you going back and forth to the bin
never add salt to eggs before cooking
them because it ruins the texture and
dulls the color instead save your
seasoning to the very end
[Music]
the key to cooking meat is to make sure
it's at room temperature before you
begin cook straight from the fridge the
mussel fibres will be tight which
results in tough meat and always let it
rest afterwards so it relaxes becoming
tender and juicy
how to de-seed chili
to get the seeds out hold it upright and
just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot
just releasing them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off
and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
smarties
from there
cut the little bottom bit off
amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilies
using string tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand
chilies are surprisingly versatile if
you love them in savory dishes my tip is
to try adding them to melty chocolate
ganache for chocolate chili truffles or
sprinkled over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon
a great tip to prevent burning sensitive
skin when working with chili's to get
rid of that spice and that heat on your
fingers a little bit of lemon squeeze a
little bit of lemon juice and that
instantly gets rid of the heat fresh
lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of cake first how to
zest the lemon
the important part is not to zest any of
the pith
watch the following technique and i'll
show you how
we've got these original graters really
important when we use this we use the
the fine zester
not the big rough one not the one for
slicing and not the other one for
grating this little one here onto a
plate because it's always easier to lift
off from the plate than it is the board
and the most important thing about
zesting a lemon is nice long strokes
but
twisting
the lemon round every time we go down we
twist
same with the orange and same with the
line
a little tap
if you go too far
let me just show you
look you got that white bitter piff that
destroys the wonderful
zesty flavor and look that's what we're
looking for there this really nice
vibrant
lemon zest
delicious
garlic is a key ingredient in so many
spicy dishes my tip for finely chopping
a mincing is add a pinch of salt for
abrasion which helps break the fibers of
the garlic down for a much better result
for getting the most out of root ginger
simply remove the skin using a teaspoon
it's easier than using a knife and you
can get around the tricky bits or just
keep the skin on and give it a good wash
[Music]
never throw out vanilla pods there's a
ton of flavour left in the skin stick
inside jars of sugar and leave to infuse
great to sprinkle on cakes biscuits or
porridge
when grinding up spices if you have any
left over you can store in an airtight
jar for up to two months great for a
spicy kick to have at your fingertips
a great cheap staple how to cook the
perfect rice basmati rice the king of
all rice is light fluffy delicious and
i'm gonna show you how to cook it
perfectly
now
start off with
400 grams of rice
rice in
spot on
so what i'm gonna do now is just rinse
off the dust and the starch
cold water always
and just rinse
the rice
that stops the rice from becoming clumpy
in the pan and allows it to become
really nice light and fluffy once it's
cooked rice
into the pan now to make a plain fluffy
rice exciting we're going to infuse it
three cardamom pods
and just get the pots and just pierce
them so it allows all that flavor to
come out
cardamom pods
and then
star anise now these are beautiful whole
star anise
it makes it really nice and fragrant
salt and pepper a lot easier to season
the rice now
than it is once it's cooked you start to
break it up when you season once it's
cooked now it's basically
one part rice to one and a half part
water
600 mils always start off in cold water
cold water in
onto the gas
lid on
bring it up to the ball as quick as
possible and turn it down and let it
simmer for eight to ten minutes and
that's the secret behind cooking great
rice allow it to steam as it's cooking
do not lift that lid up
lid off
[Music]
it smells aromatic basically all the
water's absorbed the rice has doubled in
size and is nice and light and fluffy
take the staranise out
the cardamom pods they all should have
risen to the top
pods out
take your fork
fluff it through
basically just sort of starts to open
everything back up
once you've fought it through it becomes
really nice and light and fluffy
and there
that is perfectly cooked rice
always make the most of your leftovers
use last night's rice in stir fries
scrambled up with eggs or it's simple to
make a delicious fresh salad remember a
good cook wastes nothing
a great tip for stopping potatoes apples
and avocados from going brown wing cut
simply cover with water and add a
squeeze of lemon the acidity stops the
flesh from oxidizing which is what
causes the color to change
herbs are great for adding flavor
without spending a fortune to keep them
at their best simply place them in a
glass of water and they'll stay fresh
for up to a week
and if you've got extra herbs left over
save and waste by making an amazing
flavored oil
place wash and dried stems in a bottle
cover with warmed olive oil
then seal and leave to infuse great for
salads pastas and drizzling on veg
cooking pasta a great budget basic to
keep in the cupboard it can be easily
undercooked or overcooked here's how to
do it properly first water in nice large
pan to make sure the pasta's got
sufficient room to cook evenly nicely
seasoned absolutely crucial
olive oil in
that stops the pasta from sticking
together bring it up to the ball
that's the rolling boil the secret there
it stops the pasta from sticking
together and it gently rolls it around
now this is angel pasta nice thin
pasta takes three and a half to four
minutes so into the pan as it hits the
water it melts and then you turn it
round tongs as that starts to melt
gently twist that into the pan bring it
back up to the boil if you're bad at
timing then set a timer
beautiful
to test it
lift a little strand
and you can actually feel it with your
fingers still nice and firm
al dente not a bite not a strong bite
but just really nice and firm inside
definitely not crunchy and then
into a colander drain the pasta
in
a light seasoning
salt
and pepper
a tablespoon
of olive oil
mix that through
that stops it from sticking together
and look
there you go beautiful pasta al dente
cooked perfectly
a tip for making the most of spare bread
blitz leftovers into breadcrumbs great
for stuffing or crab cakes or cut into
chunks and freeze for perfect croutons
on demand or simply tear a news in a
delicious rustic salad
dried pulses like chickpeas or lentils
are great for soups and stews and cost
pennies but don't season them until the
end of the cooking or the salt makes
them go tough
for perfect boiled potatoes always start
them off in cold water and never boiling
water this way by the time the centers
of the potatoes are cooked the outside
won't be falling apart
and when you're cooking potatoes always
cook extra so there's leftovers they're
fantastic to have on hand for making my
delicious gnocchi and potato rosters for
a classic bubbling squeak with how to
skin and debone a fish the hassle-free
way
this is basically a filleted side of
salmon it's been taken off the bone and
now
skin off
pick up your knife a really nice broad
flexible
filleting knife
a little sharpen
lift up
the base of the towel and then just nick
a little bit at the end there twist the
knife
almost as if it's horizontally
underneath the salmon pull
the skin and you slice
the salmon underneath and let the knife
do the work now get your skin
flip it back over
and check you're not leaving too much
salmon on top of the skin
pull it back
and nice and slowly get the skin wrap it
around your fingers
pull the salmon
towards you and then just all the way
through
lay that down
one
nicely skinned salmon just like a
perfect snakeskin
get your knife and just run the knife
down
and then
with a pair of tweezers these are fish
tweezers but you can use normal tweezers
look for the head
up
and pull
and with the skin being removed from
underneath the salmon
the pin bones come out a lot easier
the pinboards only go
to just basically halfway
along the fillet
one nice
fillet of salmon
beautiful
[Music]
there's still plenty of flavor in the
trimmings from affiliated fish my tip is
don't waste those fish bones add to
water wine a bay leaf and some chopped
veg to make a simple but versatile fish
talk at home the perfect base for a
delicious fish soup
[Music]
a great tip for intensely flavored
stress-free veg is to steam them in
their own juices simply add to a pan
with a knob of butter and seasoning then
cook on a low heat with a lid on to lock
in the moisture
[Music]
for crispy roast potatoes you can depend
on my tip is to parboil them leave them
to steam dry then sprinkle them with
semolina or flour and give them a good
roughing up this ensures they go really
crispy in the oven
a great tip for browning meat or fish is
to dry with kitchen roll before you cook
it then you'll get a much better color
too much moisture makes the meat steam
instead of sear and you'll lose that
rich brown crust like the one i got on
those sticky pork ribs my tip for
amazing tuna capacho is to freeze it
first and it will slice beautifully
it's wise to save leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine in freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
[Music]
when you freeze soups or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
a great tip for a cheese homemade ice
cream buy a high quality vanilla ice
cream and make it your own by mixing in
berries chocolate or my favorite rum and
boozy raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
first up how to join the chicken for
your favorite real fast food dishes
open up the legs and just pierce the
skin there careful not to cut into the
breast
and hand on top of the breast and pull
the drum back
pop out
and then slice the knife
straight across
there's the thigh there's the drum get
your thumb and feel
the joint and with the weight of the
knife
just slice these through now two
beautiful thighs
now a bit of a chef's tip halfway down
the drum just sliced through
onto the bone
and then from there
scrape the tendons
and then
hand down nice and firm on top
now
this beautiful bone presentation as it
cooks it cooks evenly
now pull out the wing
feel where the end of the joint is and
just slice in there
through
a beautiful big whole delicious wing now
this
is the rolls-royce part two breasts
that's the breast bone there
place the chicken on the board and then
just slice down on the back of the crown
everyone always cuts around just tilt it
upwards
straight through that way we get
straight
to the center of the carcass and
therefore there's no waste
and look
we end up taking off these plump
chicken breasts
nice two drums two thighs two wings
two breaths of chicken and one amazing
carcass for a stock and not an ounce of
waste
a great tip to stop your skewers burning
when you're making kebabs is to soak
them in water first or for skewers with
added flavour strip your rosemary
branches of their leaves and use instead
[Music]
for no fuss marinading my tip is to
place fish or meat in a plastic storage
bag while they marinate it's easy to
store and there's less cleanup
lime juice or lemon juice make great
marinades
my tip for getting maximum amount of
juice from a lemon or lime is to roll it
hard under your palm for a minute before
juicing
lemons are also useful for rice add a
couple of drops of juice while you cook
it to keep your grains looking nice
white and bright i want to cut my steak
rare so by touching the steak i want the
same feedback
as it is on the inside of my thumb
that's rare
as it starts to cook it gets a lot
firmer
medium is there semi-firm with a slight
resistance well done it's there
rare
a great tip for getting meat or fish to
cook faster is to score it which allows
the heat to penetrate quicker this also
allows marinades to be absorbed more
deeply
for stain-free tupperware
coat it thinly with oil which acts as a
barrier between plastic and food
it's so easy to make your own chili
sherry to use in quick stir-fries or
sauces take 450 mls of dry sherry such
as fino and using a funnel pour into a
sterilized bottle
add five whole thai chilies seal with a
cork or lid and leave to infuse for a
couple of weeks
my tip for using any discarded chili
seeds is plant them to grow yourself
some new chili peppers plant in an egg
shell or seedling trays start them
indoors and move outside when they're
ready
you